it's good to see you again thank you
yeah you too the last time we saw each
other was on set a death and life of
John F Donna Ben seems like a long time
to remember me
I do you do we were on the red carpet
did a scene together yes that's right
yeah yeah but I don't think I made the
cut a lot got cut out of the movie again
I wouldn't fell it was just you I'm so
happy the film is here at TIFF finally
and to see you shine in this movie how
would you describe John and what he was
going through look I mean he's a he's a
and oh good drama is it a person going
through an extraordinary set of
circumstances and and his extraordinary
circumstances that he's a very famous TV
actor who is hiding his sexuality I mean
I can relate to him on many fronts but
one thing I haven't had to do is hide my
sexuality I I think that he's an
incredibly lonely figure because of that
and I think he's he's a very lost person
because of it and I think he has been
abused by this situation he's in and so
I you know I could bring a lot of my own
personal experience of being in the
public eye through TV show and they come
in loneliness that might bring but I
couldn't relate to him
I had to stretch a bit with the other
stuff some of the secrets the answer he
has to keep well you talk about your own
experiences when he what do you think
about Fame dude do you like it that's a
hard question
you know I look I there's a lot of good
things about Fame and there's a lot of
bad things as well yeah and it can be a
very lonely place and a place where you
can can feel very misunderstood I I
don't strive for fame I genuinely don't
and I've experienced through Game of
Thrones about as much as I want you know
I know just what I want to work as an
actor and I think I'd be lying to say
that I never sought it out like I think
every young actor wants to be recognized
for their work and wants the kind of
flash lights
but III I've had about as much as I can
I can take yeah I think I wouldn't want
anymore
I'll be greedy and it's mostly
congratulations on getting married and
you know what is it four months now
no it's only two and a half that's it
yeah something about two and a half
three months maybe yeah
congratulations yeah you don't